[Music]
ready good morning welcome to I or 3:10
sandboxing your containers with G Weiser
I know that the keynote is still going
going on so thank you for coming from
the beginning so I'm very excited about
that
my name is Yoshi I'm product manager on
Google soccer Bernese engine I mostly
focus on the multi-tenancy which will
clue the sandbox and advisor that we're
going to talk today and hardware
accelerator which I gave a talk on
Tuesday about GPU and the one that we
launched cloud TPU in Kiruna is engine
so a little bit different but uh that's
what I do at work and we have in here
yeah and I mean Luis I'm a developer
advocate at Google I focus on kubernetes
and on extensibility and security in
Cabrini's thank you alright then let's
get started well I think it's getting
very very obvious but uh containers are
really really exploding and if I look
back the kind of a I use I I'm a
computer geek and I've been looking into
virtual machine although computer
technologies for quite a bit of time
it's so kind of a impressive to see
where containers and Canaries are today
Google has been investing in technology
containers for more than a decade really
more than a tenth in more than ten years
ago and it has been poor part of you
know how we run the service and nowadays
really run like more than four billion
containers kind of launching every week
and that's a really really huge number
but when I look at back the kind of
history when Google started the
container effort in the leanest
community it was more like a technology
and it was indeed used you know there
but I think we all agree that docker
container that came in around 2013
provide a huge value in terms of
developer experience so before the
container was one way of doing the
computer isolation but it became more
like tools right like tools and Packard
and how you share it and that was
actually very impressive at that point I
was not working at Google but it was
very very thin
thing to happen then Kearney's coming to
play because Google has the experience
of running to continue in a large scale
and now people start seeing container
right rather than the technology more
like a tool and you know to increase the
productivity and portability then this
problem about how do we deploy the
container how we run container scale
become a much more you know important in
a critical problem and that's exactly
why we open-source crew varnish today so
like this code that in its beautiful
incriminates the liam's of the cloud
it's super impressive and super you know
kind of amazing to kind of see that now
how korean is and the containers are
helping people's day-to-day workflow
that we're seeing today well then
however as many kind of a popular
technologies security becomes concerns
right like if your technology or product
it's not popular how many people using
then well you can actually you know a
little bit lower bar the security well I
will definitely still advocate the
security should be coming in first but
in reality if you're busy with something
it comes afterwards but apparently
because containers on Cabrini's are so
pervasive and you know widespread now
the security is you know real problem
and in fact security you know people who
participated to the cloud cloud native
computer computing foundation folks
there's a certain you know in the survey
security remains there's the top
challenge above anything like literally
43 percent of the respondents raised
that security is the top one another is
like storage and monitor networking if
you look at monitoring today it's one of
the haasan's in the in the in the school
next but still I think the security is
the top one and then you have a lot of
sessions also that has been happening at
this next two so I will strongly
recommend that in in addition to this
talk and if you're interested in Korean
age I think a lot of talks have been you
know are going to happen today but for
those that are going to happen you know
yesterday the day before
strongly recommend to watch a video to
augment the things that were
to talk about so because I mentioned
that you know Google runs containers you
know for a long time and that's true so
I get a lot of kind of questions like
okay so how are you guys
handling this isolation you know
concerns around containers and it's a
very good question and I feel lucky to
be part of Google because I can't
actually ask the same question to my
colleagues who are in this in this room
like so how are you guys were running
how are you guys you know dealt with
this and not only the product or project
but I can also listen to you know a lot
of you know back behind the scenes
stories there and hopefully this could
be kind of interesting for you so
there's a very very long history and
like I said like more than ten years ago
so long history of really exciting you
know trying Fanny and but exploring the
best way to run application with the
proper isolation so let's try it you
know let's rewind the clock a little bit
and see what weird you know what we have
done in the past so take one
Ranas route this is very bold statement
I still feel kind of nervous to say so I
checked with my tech leave a couple
times it is real like did you really
guys run things at root and the answer
was yes and apparently nothing shields a
system your process can basically access
all devices there or of course you can
access whole file system your files need
a host file system all resources
available for you can configure network
as you like and you can for me for home
any system calls of course and even you
can send secure locking sick ill to
others so it's pretty pretty pretty and
when I saw accurate about the service
one I'm pretty impressed in a different
way and of course what if it goes wrong
of course right and this RM IRF and star
still this kind of a sequence of
characters make me nervous right I'm
pretty sure that everyone in this room
has kind of experienced this once or
twice in the whole career and kind of
regretted your data is gone of course
but more seriously that mr. operations
you know is a real thing but more in the
form a secure
Cantus what if the malicious sauce offer
you know take advantage of this and
basically there's no answer right so
take two Rona is um for this user right
yeah this is should do by default so
basically give away the privilege of
fruit you don't need it you'll you have
only limited access to those devices
including network devices file system of
course will be limited and what kind of
system calls that you can call will be
also check and block if not and also the
sending a signal capability will be also
limited so great
very good enough but what if uh what if
the process can have a capability to set
the you out PID or like I you can create
a raw socket you know you can still do
something there so now take three
dropping capabilities Linux has a
concept call keep out functionally call
capabilities which would split the
capability of that is aggregated to rule
into a much more finer ring you know
basically fewer capabilities then
basically you have you know you have a
better isolation there so for example
like loading a kernel module which is
apparently a big you know big thing
admin capability capability to setting
the system clock and networking and the
list goes on and on and on so okay now
we have the capability so we somehow
managed to set what a process can do and
you know what a process cannot do but
what if a process can you know consume
all the resources what about the
resource isolation we have you don't
have anything so take four C groups so
to address a resource isolation problem
Google has been have you know in the
past contributed the
a control group which will allow
limiting the resources and accounting
them for a better isolation for example
it will limit access to the CPUs and it
was so accounts of CPUs by that
particular C group and saying for a
limit and account for the memory usage
you could even assign pores and memories
to a memory note to a particular group
and also you can also control the access
to the device based on the seating it
with C group that you're in great now we
have we are going to figure out why how
the process what the process can do when
your resource will be limited but still
a process can see others you can see so
see what others are doing take five
name space I actually didn't know but
name states actually existed long time
ago and I was looking you know yesterday
I was looking at in the past this when
the secret was proposed this name
integration with namespace happen at
that time so businesses basically
provides you that visibility that
isolation for the each name size type
and for example I can network in PID
mount point user IPC a lot of things so
with this name space and also the
resource limitation your resource
isolation with C groups it's a huge
advance at later it's a huge improvement
I think it took quite a bit like I'm
pretty sure was like two or three years
I when I start seeing a proposal from
Google back in 2007 - I think so it's a
huge huge improvement compared to what
Linux was at that time I think it
doesn't I think I'm not sure how it's
doing today but you know from the
original concept was more from the
Solaris zones but I was always told out
you know the US doesn't have that
capability but at this point I think I
the it was very clear that now there's a
so called container capability inside
there so it's great and I hope you know
I hope
I'm done we're talking about this but
you know life is unfair someone said a
very inconvenient truth containers do
not contain it's a very short word but
it's so true it points out the
fundamental part that we will kind of a
talk about this really it's so the same
is really so powerful that it reveals
you know what's a fundamental challenge
about isolating processes and containers
but you might ask I think I also wasn't
paying so much attention until I
realized this point but but okay but you
have some sort of isolation from a
visibility capability in a resource
consumption why why are we so focused on
about this containers not contained and
I think it's a you know great question
so we're focus about on containers not
to contain because what we're discussing
here is about the threats from the
inside of those containers and that
would you know then you know like this
picture
you know we're assuming this cat this
cute cat is the attacker and the victim
or the Paras there you one wonder like
who actually put that cat inside the
cage like who actually put a thread
inside a container and yes that's
understanding that threat model is very
very important there are two major cases
I mean I think there are more detail
keys but just very roughly two types two
types one is for a so if you're running
a service that allows user to submit
code like SAS and multi-tenancy like for
us perhaps a Google App Engine could be
a kind of a good example very obvious
case I think that I'm aware of
if you're running a WordPress and you
all perhaps allow users to use their
favorite pouring or their own customized
plugin and there you go you have a code
that you haven't been able to stratify
and that's the one particular problem
that a particle case that it could
actually put the
inside your system the other one which
is somewhat relevant is a security
breach yes attack first of all like
firewall and everything you would want
to first prevent any thread coming into
your system however we all know that we
do our best but you know there's
something happening so once that
incident happens the you know the
biggest principle that we have in Google
ensure security we have to have multiple
layers of security so if you're if you
only have one bar then it says
compromised and then it gets in then
your entire system is at risk but with
you you know so then if you have a
attacker coming into one of your
container if you don't have anything
protecting or containing inside at that
point then all the center one attack
will be of you know could affect the
rest so those are things that we wanted
to be careful and especially the latter
case you're running a system for a
larger organization right if you're if
you have a full control where what kind
of code you go I think your chances of
you know getting to that problem is
lowered but if you have a much more
distributed you know teams with a lot of
different kind of a background then you
may or may not be able to control that
fully so if you want to be you know if
you guys want more scare or like agility
then you actually might want to think
about really containers to contain the
threat inside okay so what were here so
when we talk about the current threat
from the inside what we're talking about
is we're we're talking about attack you
know through the Linux kernel which will
allow this containers to escape outside
of the isolation that we talked earlier
they they usually exploit bugs inside on
leanness kernel by with a sent through a
system service like obvious one system
call but like /proc files and to bypass
the all the long history of the atom
mechanism in silence kernel and bypass
that and eventually elevate the
privilege so escape and
and attacked a chronal and then break it
and take the polish of the system so
this is the kind of a you know very
high-level is more detailed but that is
the kind of overall picture of the
threat that we're talking at the attack
that we're talking about so a Linux
kernel you may not notice because it's
so widely used and indeed it's you know
it's great it's a lot of people paying
attention of security but reality is
that it has huge attack surface just by
numbers there are around 320 more than
300 system calls there there are more
than 2000 TVs reported since 1999 out of
which more than 200 or pervious
escalations so I'm not trying to
actually really you know criticize about
the Linux kernel it's like I said in the
early like like I mentioned earlier if
your project product Co gets popular
then two things happen right well you
add more features that you have to
commune respond to more of those in
functionality then the system gets
complex and then we forget more
popularity than you have chances of
attackers paying attention to attack
those you know attack the you know the
the proud of a project you guys you know
more more audience than they want it to
be more effective when they think about
the attack one of the most famous one I
think of that pattern of the attack is
dirty Cal that happened to a report in
2016
it's a privilege escalation of
vulnerability inside a Linux kernel and
on privileged local user could exploit a
race condition race condition in the
copy and write so therefore how
mechanism in the Linux kernel subsystem
to increase their progress on the system
so I honestly I was really at Google
working at Google and I was always
arguing about so what is the right
isolation for containers and I was more
on a camp of well containers should be
doing very well right if you hardness
and if you have these firms you should
be good know but this dirty cow came up
and it was a different security team but
they made sure that yeah there's dirty
cow and this one
and then they're really open oh my god
open up my I said okay so if it's a
complex system then literally we have to
be prepared for unexpected situation so
to be fair there are tools for experts
on all see why I say experts but one is
selinux and armed and more based on
linear security module which is a
mandatory access control which provides
fine-grain you know access control per
process so it will really you can
describe very well on what a process can
do and cannot do the second one second
BPF a sec comm is a kind of short for
secure computing mode inside Linux and
this - PPF the BBB Birkett packet filter
is a it's a filler by itself but what
what it means by the circum BPF is that
you can actually specify the policy by
using language coming with the BPF and
apply to second and it's an extension of
that annual you can define you know
which fill which cisco should be filters
with BPF rules just to kind of give you
example before coming to Korea news
engine team I worked at a promising and
I actually did bring in entry apps to
Chrome OS so I had a lucky I have a kind
of a lock to look into both Chrome OS
and Android the same time and it's
interesting to me because Android use as
a linux intensively and the Chrome OS
use seccomp intensively what it means
that is selinux in android and working
app compatibility is very important so
you actually want to have why cisco to
cover or the framework to cover
therefore you need to hard and I mean
you know the leanest kernel very
strictly and they even have a test suite
and also the policy that you have to
sort of get certified to be named as
android on earth hanging Chrome OS
they're using second vpf to sandbox the
Chrome browser rendering and the
philosophy there is that to reduce the
tax surface
because there's only browser there's no
the browser is the application framework
so all you wanted to focus is what the
browser is going to say to the system so
yeah we have a system and the question
is are these two for me maybe for you
and if you do know you know the policy
very well if you know what application
you want for it like I said in the front
you know chrome you know case Chrome OS
browser you know and then it's great but
the problem is that the more descriptive
you get the more detail you describe in
a policy the chances of that pulse to be
generic I mean other process will be
lower because it's very specific so you
are first of all your main app may not
run with those policies so the isolation
wise we have another one you know called
making a V n as isolation boundary which
is true but then the downside there is
that well you have to launch a VM and
then you have to run a kernel large or
small it's still kernel it's for just
one container or one process it's not
unnecessary effective or elastic as a
regular process so okay so we talked
about various things there's no pros and
cons so what do you think
and you think or we have all the right
tools for us what do you want right so
at Google we looked at a number of
different solutions right we talked
about we looked at things like set comp
we look at things like selinux and an
app armour and we looked at things like
vm solutions and there's trade-offs
between all of these different things
and so the the thing that we saw a like
that we would have to make trade-offs
with is that we wanted things we wanted
our containers to be secure so that that
attackers that have gotten control of
the container can't break out of the
container we wanted something that was
like less configuration or ideally zero
configuration something that was kind of
like a self-driving car here where it's
kind of turnkey solution something we
just get in and go we don't have to
configure per application you know
filters or like per application writes
some sort of selinux or app armor policy
we want to just be able to run our
applications unmodified another was that
we wanted to have something that was a
lightweight something we ran a lot of
containers and so we wanted something
that was gave a similar experience to
what we were used to so we want
something that's lightweight doesn't use
a lot of resources and gives us lower
low memory and CPU overhead and so we
looked at these and we saw that we had
to make a lot of trade-offs but we
thought why would what if we didn't have
to make these trade-offs what if we
could get everything that we wanted in a
system we could make you know we could
maybe make different trade-offs and then
get all of the things that we wanted
here and so we came up with something
called G Pfizer so G Weiser is a sandbox
for containers and it implements a
independent user space kernel and so
this runs in user space you like
separate from the Linux kernels so it
gives you an extra level of isolation
and so as we were doing this we were
like you know the Linux system call
interface is like this you know wide
attack surface and but you can think of
it kind of like an epi the links provide
Linux kernel provides you an API that
your application is being used to
execute themselves and get resources so
what if we just made a different
implementation of that API and we ran
that in userspace and that's how we came
up with the idea for G Weiser and so
it's a it's a link it's a user space
kernel that implements these system
calls so it's similar to something like
user space Linux except where we have
our own kernel rather than trying to run
Linux itself in user space
and so this gives us the kind of high
security that we want it's a user space
kernel that implements the assists calls
and it's written in go and the reason
why we did it and go is because we got a
good trade-offs when using go between
the memory and typesafe type safety of
the language runtime as well as the
speed
as and we also get this kind of Linux
user space kernel so that even if the
attacker gets control of the the
container application then they find
some sort of bug in the devisor even if
they do that they still don't have
control of the system they're still
stuck in user space so they can't just
execute everything as the kernel and get
full access to the whole host gee visors
also zero config we can run unmodified
Linux applications because we implement
the Linux iskills applications can we
can just run them in the sandbox and
have them use the that kernel and so we
don't read to write any filters or
profiles or like security profiles
things like that in order to get our the
least privilege for our by applications
typically for those type of filters you
would need to know what the application
needs to use what capabilities it needs
what sis calls it's running it's using
and what sort of resources it needs from
the operating system in order to
actually configure your lease privilege
for the application but with g5i we can
just run the application in the sandbox
and we don't need to do these kind of
configurations it's also very light and
quick so it's very similar to the kind
of experience that we got when running
normal containers right so we have
basically a 15 megabyte or so memory
footprint this kind of can kind of
change depending on the application and
how it you actually uses the gee visor
user space kernel
but in general you get something around
a 15 megabyte memory footprint so you
get just that amount of overhead and
also you can startup applications in
around 150 milliseconds so this is very
similar to the way that the containers
run we don't have to start up a kind of
have a lot of startup time or a lot of
overhead associated with our sandbox
so this really fit well with our a kind
of model and fit well with our kind of
container orchestration within Google
and so we use the G Visor for a number
of things within Google but one of the
more obvious things that like Yoshi
mentioned and this is a tweet from our
director or ring we use it we think
cloud platform for particularly for
things where applicate where users need
to upload application code and we run it
on their behalf
so we don't want to be have a situation
where somebody can upload code and then
get access to somebody else's
application or break out of a container
and then read some other users users
data that would be a pretty bad security
breach so what we want is to provide a
sandbox to run these applications and so
for things like App Engine cloud
functions and cloud ml this is a perfect
fit for us in order to run applications
within a sandbox like this and then we
decided that this was a particularly
interesting technology and this is
something that now that containers are
becoming more ubiquitous and more
popular and things like orchestration
systems like kubernetes are starting to
become popular and people are starting
to build passes and all kinds of
different systems on top we thought that
G pfizer would be something that users
outside of Google could take advantage
of in order to provide these type of
type of solutions and so we open sourced
eight and it's now it's a it's on github
at github slash Google /d visor we open
sourced it in May this year at coop con
and the the response was enormous like
it was quite a lot more than we expected
within ten days we had 5,000 github
stars and we have over 60 6,400 today so
thanks for to all of you who have
started github and us on github and who
are kind of following the project
but the response has been enormous and
we're really kind of interested in how
how we can kind of take this further and
integrate this with other kind of
kubernetes there with kubernetes and
other orchestration systems but before
we do that let's take a look back at the
actual architecture of and kind of dive
deep a little bit deeper into the
architecture of G visor so G visor is a
system for running a sandbox and we so
we have our user space kernel but we
wanted to make something that was made
it easy for folks to run containers in
our sandbox and so we provide a OCI
interface OCI compatible interface so if
you're a docker user you may be can
submit with run C which is the OCI
runtime for containers and G visor
provides a command called run SC that is
essentially a drop-in replacement for
run C and provides this OCI
implementation so we can run OCI bundles
for containers in a sandbox very easily
and so once you start up a container
that containers application it is loaded
into into memory along with the the
century which is the which is our kernel
in the user space and the application is
loaded into the same into the centuries
user memory and then the application is
executed but as we are executing it
the Sentry has two different types of
modes one is a KVM mode and one is a p
trace mode and what these do is these
intercept this is calls that the
application makes and then handles them
inside the century so inside of the the
user space kernel so we don't actually
go into the kernel in order to handle a
lot of the SIS calls that we're making
the Sentry does actually have to make a
few sis calls to the Linux kernel itself
but that surface area is very highly
reduced compared to a normal container
so Yoshi mentioned that we had 319 total
sis calls for the Linux Cisco API and
the century narrows that down to a
surface area of something along the
lines of between 10 and 20 so something
like that and then we have and because
we know what the Sentry needs in terms
of its its own sis calls we can then put
a set comm profile on that and further
lockdown so that only those dis calls
are the ones that can actually be run by
the century and so even if an
application if somebody's able to take
control of an application and then they
find some sort of bug in the century
some sort of buffer overrun or something
like that that they're able to execute
code as the century they're still locked
into this user space sandbox that can
only run a few sis calls and so they're
not actually you're not actually able to
do anything very much at that point the
sandbox actually can't even write to the
file system when actually locations need
to write to the file system the century
writes to or uses a separate process
that we start up for the container
called a gopher and we use the 9p
protocol in order to send our to do file
IO and things like Network IO so that
type of IO is not something that you can
actually do just unlimited even if you
can take care of this even if you can
execute code as the century so this
gives us a quite a a good sandbox for
for applications to run for untrusted
code it gives us a very good set
isolation from the kernel but as we said
like everything is every thing that you
do is trade-offs right I said that
earlier that we we didn't want to make
the trade-offs between security zero
config and having lightweight containers
but that means that we have to make that
we have to make trade-offs in some other
place right and so there are some things
that we have to add as caveats to
running things in G Weiser so some
applications let's walk through some of
the applications that might be impacted
by running in G Weiser sandbox the first
of those is cisco heavy workloads so
because g Weiser is implementing these
Siskel's in user space
it's a kernel that's using the go
runtime and just by let by the fact of
its use be running user space that
there's a slight difference in things
like you know running kernel code is is
running as a higher priority on the cpu
and things like that so you will get
some performance impact so things the
applications that might run yeah lots of
syscalls in a tight loop those are the
type of applications that are going to
be impacted by running performance wise
by running in G Weiser there's also the
idea of sis call coverage and
compatibility so G pfizer itself
implements many of the Linux this calls
but it doesn't implement every single
last one of them at least not currently
and so there's a total of 319 but we
implement around 211 and those are some
of the more highly used ones but it also
means the applications that use those
sis calls that we don't implement will
not will have some compatibility issues
the last is the last thing that I want
to highlight as a caveat is direct
access to hardware so applications that
need direct access to hardware will are
potentially not a great fit for G Weiser
and that's because partly because just
of the nature of the fact that we are
running in a sandbox providing direct
access to hardware from a security
standpoint is very risky because you
have direct access to the hardware you
can do whatever you want so if the
application is compromised in time the
entire host is generally compromised and
so G Weiser doesn't have the concept
that that a normal Linux kernel does of
device drivers and things like that and
so direct access to hardware like GPUs
or others
specialty hardware may not be a good fit
for G Weiser
at least not right now great so that's
out of the way let's uh let's actually
take a look at a couple of these the
vulnerabilities the first one is dirty
Cal and the second one is Melton and
we'll just kind of take a look at how G
Weiser might mitigate a couple of these
vulnerabilities and kind of explain what
they do and then how G Weiser kind of
mitigates them alright so let's switch
over to the demo machine
can we show you yeah can we switch over
to the demo machine here thank you all
right great let's make this a little bit
bigger so we're gonna do here is I'm
going to use just I'm gonna run a an
application that takes akin takes a
makes use of the dirty Cal exploit and
run isn't just a normal a container to
see show you what happens when you do
that so what happens here is what I have
here is I have a an OC I bundle so this
is just a regular container so you can
think of this is just a container that's
been unpacked or a container image
that's been unpacked to the file system
and we're gonna run this using run see
so if we just do like 20 here of the
config we can see we're going to run an
application here inside the container
we're gonna write some data to the exact
password we're running this as a as a
user not as root so normally this the
user wouldn't be able to write to this
file what we're gonna do is we're gonna
write this this little string here spam
into the exact password file which is
not something that you would normally be
able to do but because of dirty cow
exploiting dirty cow you're able to do
that so when we run it inside a normal
container we're gonna do C do C run we
got to give it a name here so we'll just
say dirty cow so when we've run this
application what this is doing is it's
taking can taking advantage of a race
condition in the Linux kernel what this
is doing is doing a couple of sis calls
in two different threads at the same
time in a kind of a tight loop and when
it gets it the the kernel state in just
the right place it's able to write to a
file that it that regardless of what
permissions are associated with that
file and so what we're doing here
if this uses two different Cisco's one
of them is the EM advises call and one
is a Peter a Cisco but the M advises
goal is once
that is highly used in normal
applications so this is something that's
very hard to actually filter out of an
application so like you know you can't
necessarily just put on a set comp
policy - not that you can't run em
advised or something like that because I
mean flies is used in pretty much every
application out there so even if you're
able to know what your application uses
for things like Siskel's
you're not always able to just filter
out those syscalls
like some of them you actually need to
be using ok so here the applications
finished its run through our tight loop
and has been able to take advantage of
dirty Cal and so what we'll do here is
we'll take a look at the actually we
need to run look at the root filesystem
here and we'll look at the password file
and scroll up here so we'll actually
able to see here that we've written to
the beginning of this file here so you
can imagine that we've we could
overwrite just lines in this file add a
new root password and just get privilege
escalation that way so it's very easy to
to get privilege escalation when you can
just write to any file on the file
system so this is something that's
really really bad for us so let's switch
over and take a look at running it in G
pfizer
so when we do this we have the exact
same OCI runtime here or the same OCI
bundle we're going to do a show you here
just the exact same configuration we're
running it's the same user we're using
the same application we're going to
write to the same file and the same with
the same content but this time we're
going to use run SC for G visor so we're
gonna do su do run a C I'm gonna add a
couple of flags in here just to show
some debug information to show you
what's going on because otherwise it
would just kind of sit here and run
all right so when we run it in G Weiser
we're able to actually run the
application and the application executes
exactly the same way is it wood inside
of a normal container except for what
it's doing here is it's running in two
different loops or in two different
threads and executing em advise and P
trace over and over again and so what
this is doing is just spitting out logs
every time the M advised and P trace are
called but you can see here the
application is actually running but in
the end we won't actually be able to
write to the file so if we go in here
actually I should open up another SSH
and we'll just look at the file and then
kind of verify that the file has not
actually been written to
let's do this right and then we say root
filesystem exact password so we look up
here we can see that we haven't actually
been able to write this and by nature
the this a particular attack the
attacked will just continue to run and
try to take advantage of the kernel and
as long as it's not able to it's not
it's just not able to wrote to write to
the file but it's also kind of
interesting to note that this is the
exactly the type of application that can
have a performance impact energy visor
because it's running in a tight loop and
just executing syscalls this is actually
a worst case scenario and for that but
normal applications aren't doing this
this type of thing all right so we're
able to see that we can mitigate
vulnerabilities with like dirty cow and
that's a kind of a pure Linux kernel
vulnerability but what about for other
kinds of vulnerabilities so meltdown is
another vulnerability that's very
popular and because and meltdown is a is
a combination kind of hardware
vulnerability as well as a software
vulnerability so it's this is something
that because g5 sirs is a software
sandbox we can't 100% mitigate hardware
vulnerabilities but in some sense on the
software side we can mitigate it a
little bit so for instance we are going
to run an application and use meltdown
and what meltdown does is it's kind of a
it does a it takes advantage of a
hardware bug in like kind of conditional
execution and so what you have is but
the most easy way to take advantage of
that is a in a situation where in the
past when applications were run they
would map kernel memory into the process
itself and so if you if you do that and
you have this hardware bug you're very
easily able to have
application read that be able to read
that kernel memory in any place you not
and not just places that you're able to
read but ones that you shouldn't be able
to read so here what we're gonna do is
we're gonna get the memory address of
the Linux proc banner so this is
something that's part of kernel memory
and so when an application is running
this kernel memory is mapped in and then
we're gonna do is we're going to tell
our application to read this particular
piece of kernel memory this address from
kernel memory that it normally shouldn't
be able to read so we just look at this
it's a actually oops right so like this
is just a addressing memory that we want
to try to read so if we run this in
normal docker container
all right
so we're gonna run this in a normal
document container with Runcie and we're
gonna give it our the address that we
have here and have it read out that that
memory so when we do that we're able to
see that the application is vulnerable
and that we're able to read out the
memory and the Linux proc manner just
has some information about the kernel
version and some other information so
that's not particularly a bad but other
types of reading other parts of karma on
Mary could potentially give you lots and
lot like allow you to do lots of
different types of privilege escalation
so when we run this in you know using
the same way but we run it in G visor G
visor actually doesn't map in the this
kernel memory and so we're able to
mitigate this slightly I didn't run this
with soo do
ah yes you're right
so we run this in the with divisor we're
able to see that it's not vulnerable and
because the kernel memory is not mapped
into the process that we're not able to
actually read that that memory out from
Linux proc banner so in that sense
something some things can be partially
mitigated there are other kind of
theoretical ways that you could take
advantage of of meltdown in G visor but
those are things that are that we think
are a little bit harder to to to
actually to actually get working because
the G visor has a hardened sandbox all
right great
so thank you in then back to the fly
speeds these are probably first time
during the demonstration I'll say so it
was great to actually see this in action
thank you so g visor and grenades
both are were invented at google and we
democratize that with open source both
kubernetes energy visor and what about
you guys are if you like it
there are couple things you could do for
us could go to github press Start button
you could fork it we have around 300
Fork so if you have interest in project
absolutely please for Kane would love to
hear what you could do and also perhaps
most importantly like Ian mentioned a G
visor took a different kind of a you
know a trade-off which was you know this
is called compatibility if you can run
your eye try running your application or
dinner run file a bug let us know and
you know let us know your use case I
think that's what we would love to know
just only with G visor but we want to
make this u visor accessible to
everybody through kubernetes Google
we're leading the effort of introducing
the concept called sandbox pause
specification in the kourounis community
right now and of course G visor is one
of the run times they've been proposed
for sandbox pause in Cabrini's what it
means is that well ian is a you know
great hyper so he can type in a command
nicely but you know it's not you know we
want to make it more generic meaning
we could actually let people access to G
Weiser you see Weiser through kubernetes
ma how wonderful that could be and I'm
gonna quickly talk about what we're
doing in the community
as we speak so sandbox in Crewe Brunei's
it's not done yet unfortunately it would
be great to finish up and talk wild and
yeah we're done but just see work in
progress really work in progress but it
doesn't mean that we're you know baking
things inside we're really doing this
everything in open source so if you look
at all the open source discussion you'll
see our team Eclair articulated for this
project and he's making huge progress so
the sandbox polish the kubernetes api
new crew varnish for api for the same
boss containers or pause it will be a
palpable isolation so polyfill for
people who don't know what the different
bean pod and container what's kind of
similar but part is the kind of small
the smallest granularity on the
primitive that could be scheduled by
Cremonese and inside the pot you could
have multiple containers so it will
protect this group of continued that's
part we hope that you know for anything
that's you know gonna be part of the
sandbox part will have at least you like
multiple layers of isolation boundaries
because otherwise it doesn't make so
much sense to call it a sandbox pot if
you could break up what's the difference
this is the really working progress api
i have more detail but just you know
decided to not to put too much on this
is actually the third version when I
started working a slide this is a third
version I had changed so as we speak
we're making change but I think Tim
already has a very you know close to
final forum as a submission so we'll see
how that lands in the future version
Cremonese so just to kind of give you a
sneak peek us runtime class is a new API
to specify the runtime meaning like
which runtimes I want to use for my pot
and containers you can specify runtime
which runtime class to use from the
prospect so Tim you know kind of
emphasize that you know make it V 1
alpha very clear yes it's a working on
so the name will be wrong time class and
in this case metadata name will be G
visor and the runtime handler would
specify account you know another G visor
what
thing and inside there is by which file
of the runtime to use and all the
relevant specification but that's
something that we believe that the
cluster operator so if you're running on
premise the cluster Omni will be in
charge for setting that up and in case
of plow it will probably ask you know
the cloud operator providers will be
configuring the left side of the
configuration and all you have to do
I mean users have to do is to write up a
regular prospect specimen the spec that
you're specify wrong time class name and
choose whatever you want to either urge
it we talked about divisor today but
there are also other approaches like
other container so we're working
together to standardize this
specification I think we're making huge
progress there so we talked about today
we talked about the container isolation
you know through from the past and the
present the past is like you know
iteration and the present is the what we
have open source what we have in queries
granese engine visor and of course i we
just talked about a little bit of you
know future to bring it together so if
you're interested in you know gys are
running g wiser with kubernetes engine
please let us know we will love to hear
your thoughts there so this is a link to
our forum world you can continue the
discussion in a conversation
thank you we ran out of time so
hopefully we could take questions after
it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]